la présidente nassimah dindar et la
présidente de la commission outre-mer de
départements français
voilà donc j'ai envie de faire le point
avec elle d'abord sur à quelques
semaines de notre congrès de marseille
sur ce qu'elle dira et ce qu'elle
proposera pour les départements
d'outre-mer et puis naturellement les
problématiques réunionnaise touchant à
la politique sociale et politique
financière au concours de l'état aux
grands dossiers du département de la
réunion grands dossiers d'aménagement
politique touristique à politique à
l'école
voilà c'est un département que j'aime
beaucoup je lequel on souvent de venir
comme membre du gouvernement ou comme
parlementaire avec mes collègues de la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale où j'ai pas mal d'amis et je
suis toujours heureux de devenir ivoire
à aller partement qui pour moi est assez
exemplaire de ce que peut être la
présence de la france dans certaines
zones du monde est ici dans l'océan
indien
il ya trois grandes associations d'élus
en france ce sont des maires de france
qui regroupe les trente cinq mille cinq
cents communes l'association des
départements qui regroupe 102
collectivités les majorités bien sûr de
deux départements et puis les régions à
qui regroupe les régions les 13 régions
métropolitaines et les régions
ultramarines notre rôle c'est de parler
au président de la république au premier
ministre au gouvernement au parlement
pour leur présenter nos propositions
nous revendications nos besoins de
construire en commun et donc là je
représente la voix des départements
auprès de l'état comme mon collègue
françois baroin
la représente pour les communes où
philippe richert pour les régions et
puis nous travaillons naturellement tous
ensemble parce que développer un
territoire ce n'est pas dans la
concurrence entre collectivités que ça
doit se faire c'est dans la
complémentarité des actions et c'est
qu'ici à la réunion c'est ainsi que les
choses sont comprises est fait